good afternoon everyone and welcome to
today's episode of the Friday review
we're coming to you live from sunny
mountain view where the poem is so thick
in the air that there's a good chance i
will choke right before the allergies
kill me my name is reto Meier I'm a
joined here in the studio today buy him
a present Fred Chung and the
irrepressible yours what D mabul drunk
sir Roman Nurik has it has come all the
way down from San Francisco on the one
who has how was the drive this morning I
was on I took a bus okay all right I
don't know the drug you've got the
license that's nice one so thank you for
coming down and enjoy this year so as as
always we're going to try and review a
bunch of apps today we've got five on
our list we'll get through as many as we
can anything we don't we'll put at the
top of list check out next week we hear
every week same time 1 p.m. pacific
which is I think 8 p.m. UTC something
like that so so if there's a there's
more apps you want to see there'll be
more ups every week so let's let's kick
off let's have a look at our first stop
for today I think we're going to have a
look at heart sounds and murmurs which
was at the top of our list or the bottom
of that list last week we didn't quite
get enough time to to look at so I
afraid you've just checked out a few
medical apps if I'm having a heart
attack and the first thing I do is grab
my phone before I and I'll around that
one I checked this first ride you check
this you go to Google Play and check it
so like like rates are set the title of
this app is hot sounds and murmurs and I
would characterize it as a medical
reference application let's have a look
at the tablet view here Ian
alright great thanks let's launch the
ABS this is the icon of it flipped right
into portrait mode so let's rotate
device back alright cool so this this is
a collection of different sound clips
that represents different heart
conditions and norm works hard
conditions and murmurs as you can see we
have a dark theme here which is very
nice it's got the holo theme with no
additional menu item down here and it's
got an overflow manual up on the upper
right hand corner in the action bar as
you can see on screen so it's a pretty
simple no BS application I would imagine
it's got a pretty good reference value
for people in the industry for medical
professionals and or students it shows
you a bunch of sound clips oops let's go
back and you go through a bunch of them
a lot of these don't I can't really tell
the difference meant maybe you guys can
no no no no but it's hell yeah so is
this the way it's supposed to work so
rather than listening to your own heart
it gives you the sounds that you should
be listening for if if someone has a
heart condition is Aaron yeah so it
basically illustrates a bunch of it's a
library of this library of sound clips
mo gatherin is this for medical
reference purposes I would say and based
on Google Play ratings people seem to
like it and that's why we are doing here
also so my first reaction looking at
this screen is that legibility can be
improved a little bit right because
while you have the dark theme with white
tags but i think you know especially on
the tablet you can look for
opportunities to increase the font size
a little bit to make it more legible
what do you guys think yeah absolutely i
mean you can see right away like it's
sort of the heart of each of the list
looks to be about right I know the small
text you stalked away to them to the
left and top really something yes
looking yeah exactly and especially for
a detailed text here mmm we have some
issues for the orientation but is it
something that can be controlled or do I
need to Ok Go you can break this nothing
I can do yeah a little over it's a
completely unnatural yeah it's for the
detail view soon yeah and basically when
you get into the detail view it plays
back the sound and show you this kind of
progress bar and then touching the
screen i believe touch and swipe it a
double tent was a double tap or one of
those gestures basically replays it and
it's not a hundred percent discoverable
right and you know when i looked at this
last week before we were able to
actually talk about it and we ran out of
time I didn't notice a bunch of things
here just you know it just in terms of
basic usability obviously you know on a
tablet the line lengths are really long
the font sizes are small which we
alluded to but things like you know
basic things like raising the volume of
the sound right i mean i actually found
that it was barely impala mostly
impossible to actually hear the sound
and so you may want to try to amplify it
so that it's you know at a default
volume default system volume you can
actually hear what you're you know what
it is the other thing is there's a lot
of opportunity for visuals and i know
that like sound is I mean you can't
visualize sound then you know it's not
the easiest thing to do you know show
that the waveforms or not but it may be
something that that you can add maybe
like you know if there's a pulse like
boom boom maybe you can sort of like
illustrate that somehow using the graph
right right maybe like show on a
timeline not exactly the exact waveform
but kind of like beats like circles
indicating here's where it beat is and i
would even on a tablet especially put
this on the the listing the listing of
all the sounds just so that you can
really easily scan things so if I'm a
doctor right and I'm
cheering and again I am NOT a doctor so
I know he was talking about in your
other yeah imagine like fred is having
some sort of you know issue and you know
I his heart rate or whatever it is you
know I can roughly sense oh there's like
three beats happening and their
irregular and so be really good to be
able to just scan that list very easily
and see hey where are those three beats
I'm saying here that's the one that I
want and then go into that and hear the
audio that's a great idea I think the
visualization is really important
because it's gonna be quite soul in a
lot of times what you're listening to
him seeing the waveform is going to give
you that prompt as to what it is you're
listening for ya it's really really neat
trick in that tablets rebooted cell
phone right yeah just our duty how to
device Sam now that's an interesting
point actually because he would not
install on my on my ICS phone device so
that's kind of interesting I mean having
having looked at it here I don't see any
reason why it shouldn't be available on
phone tan in fact it looked like a
layout that was sort of optimized for
phones more certain tablets now right so
I would say that to the developers check
that out make sure that you're not
limiting your app to you know fewer
devices capable of running on actually I
verify that on verify that this very
same app on the phone and it works it
works yeah it's one of the few apps that
have no special permissions it's a
self-proclaimed application of Internet
permission you know internet connection
it's got it's gotten the auto sound
clips available within the APK itself
which is I've cool very nice yeah um I
didn't want to mention a couple of other
things very quickly if you guys have any
other comments but um the launcher icon
was extremely dim embodies that you
can't see this but the launcher icon was
pretty much just like a black background
and like some very wiry like shape i
think it was in the form of a heart but
it was almost impossible to discern what
was what was it what was representing so
i would definitely recommend using comic
maybe even a non-square launcher icon he
one in the shape of a heart so something
like that also the default holo theme is
fine I personally prefer the dark action
bar theme Holloway action bar that's
something that I think always adds a
nice touch to apps yeah and the last bit
was on the sound detail screen like when
you get into the detail screen you saw
that there is like there is an action
bar with no title and then there are two
fake titles or titles underneath the
action bar I just want to know to
everybody that the action bar actually
supports both the title and a subtitle
so and since the the length of the text
wasn't that long it seems you could
probably represent you know the title of
the screen in the action bar itself so
you have the the sound name at the top
as a title and then under that you have
the subtitle which I think was kind of
like a category or kind of a further
smaller description so you can easily
avoid having to extra UI elements on
your screen and then that will leave
more space for like the waveform for
example but all right okay so i think
we'll move on to our next step we're
fortunate enough to have the development
for this app online as well with us
today so this is real colors pro really
interesting app I'm going to fire it up
here on on the tablets but while that
cup or on the phone i should say but
while that comes up did you want to tell
us a little bit about your actin and
sort of the concept behind here should
so we're free guys and basically in DF
expects color schemes color palettes
thrown pitches from photos from the
energy camera that's what we're
basically trying to do and the goal is
for designers to get inspiration from
real life from teachers from sites very
nice oh yes so let's say let's switch to
the authority here we can we
look at it straight away you can see
it's a really nice looking at sort of a
really beautiful intro here which I
really like then you've got your ear
actions right here now these aren't
standard buttons or anything like that
but I think it's pretty clear straight
away that are there actionable so try
and choose a picture from the gallery on
this from this policy what we have here
of course it's my things is awesome I
got some pictures here so much so let's
go with this it's gravy i'll see it
didn't work interesting something went
wrong sit so I one question for you yeah
is it supposed to work on anything from
the gallery so including things which
have to be downloaded or as adjust
things which are going to be already on
the phone so yeah the problem with jared
is that the new legality doesn't return
correct your eye on all phones sometimes
it returns on free 3.0 returns HTTP 8
address so he'll get from the internet
and some on 4.0 some get some version of
gallery returns the correct your eye but
some doesn't return like conduct google
that android or counter android so we
try to fix most of the tool to see share
we're trying to have like hardcore stuff
inside the app so we can get all the
obit in the picasa that some problems
with it because I depending on the
version of the candida use cash energy
if you this is probably something more
for our office hours but if you get back
you are I that starts with content right
and when you query it gives you an error
then that's definitely about we use exit
yeah it's it's own code its own issues
a lot of people commented I okay well
okay so in the meantime I'm going to
take a photo with our room in here to
see if we can get a color scheme expect
to see some screen to agreement black
and brown so this is uh this is a
picture of about hangout rigged with the
other couch sure which you guys move to
before so let's see what kind of color
scheme you should trip rope for begin
work for course yeah sorry typing in
support remote so it's nice to know
works and it works in landscape and
stretch between portrait and landscape
that doesn't lose the progress of what's
doing which is all really nine rennet
this is kind of the main screen this is
where the magic happens and again it
it's really attractive it looks really
nice you get this sort of a suede sort
of graph of the colors in the scene
instead of the more vivid and more
colorful the scene is obviously the
movie that this graph is so though this
isn't the best example because it's a
very sort of playing image that we're
taking but you get you get the idea here
you've got that sort of color wheel and
the nation colors which exists in the in
the photo are represented there yeah
it's a great app for shopping for paint
absolutely right yeah random reading a
room or something if you want to have a
house that looks nice but have
absolutely no design skills are we going
to be useful like me yeah people at four
pump owners support and out support
right very hands-on now is really great
yeah so again you can go through here
and so this is real so this is
presenting I presume a list of colors
represented within the images ara yes
every all by all rules we get that only
colors that are in the image so real is
like our matrix thoughts if you want and
yeah the rules are standard in color
theory go ahead with complementary so
yeah we can go through here and take
like complementary colors to the ones
listed an image in cities these are the
sorts of things you would use to try and
you know it's kind of painting the room
it picks up in complementary it's kind
of like a Dobby color k cooler sorry
exactly yeah it's like a very cooler but
taking a real image as a source very
very close now as we've got a whole
bunch of different of different options
here shades split complimentary bunch of
stuff that I have no idea what the
meaning of is but all of which give you
these sort of range of colors that suit
the the scene and you can kind of click
through each of these colors and edit
them and modify them to set sort of
customize them exactly the way that you
want using you know a bunch of different
techniques you know for color
notification and then there's a couple
of nice tips as well here you can create
a wallpaper using using the ether color
three nice exported so one of the
comments I wanted to make here is on the
export window where it's here it's sort
of hard coded to export to mail it would
be nice if this was more of a share or
ascend to implementation where you know
you can specify the message that you
want to send it and which things that
you want to attach to it but then let
the user distribute that help they want
whether it's through mail or thread
mother right how do you actually export
the color values that you know I'm
guessing you don't know just export
hacks do you like create an image or do
creation Maya it's an HTML with
beautiful colors and the details will
get that month or so you wanted one
thing you may want to consider doing is
maybe rendering to a bitmap saving that
as a PNG and allowing sharing that PNG
through whatever service be it face down
our necks and a dime for any coalition
to have like a one image that represents
everything in one place yeah so what
you're doing here is actually sending it
sending an email but not using any of
the clients on the device I definitely
think about changing that so that you're
just packaging up the contents for an
email which can be sent using it the
gmail or you know the email or wherever
else I've got installed that means you
have to have a picture because it
couldn't send HTML if right hand of the
that's very true and so similar along
similar lines if we go if we go back to
the scheme you've got the share button
and I think right now that that links
directly to Facebook so again it'll be
nice if this was just the standard sent
to intense so you can send it by a
Twitter Facebook Gmail some kind of oil
a lot more flexible absolutely because I
have most people on Twitter who love my
color suggestions for not so much on
facebook that yeah we basically need to
find because we need to push the images
on some server so we can if you want to
share it with everybody so they can
access it now that's why we hard-coded
in on facebook like if you want to share
for all with all the apps what me Sam
you need to send you you are in right
but they need so you basically you
basically just have to attach in your
action when you fire off action send
right you basically have to have a
content provider I believe that allows
the the app like Google+ or Facebook to
access your image then that app will
take care of uploading it to the server
and doing whatever it needs to so
basically you only have to have a local
copy of that PNG and then the app that
actually does the sending will take it
from get it from your app using a
content provider and then upload it to
their service okay I didn't know that
that I thought I need to okay I'll check
it out but I think I thought even for
some so they they uploaded themselves
yes I mean okay so you just if you the
very simplest thing to do obviously if
you're like Google+ right is to just
accept the URL and show a preview of
that URL and if that URL as an image
then it just shows the image but google
plus i believe i mean again this is up
to the app i'm just thinking of take
another one drop box for example dropbox
is definitely a case where if you try to
give them an image they're not gonna
sore the URL they'll actually take the
image and upload it into your account
that's one definite example okay so
definitely if that's definitely going to
help you out you feel a lot of
flexibility that which
which i think is going to be really
useful otherwise you know if we're just
talking about the app in general the
look and feel I love the the way you've
done navigation here it's not the way
that we necessarily always suggest that
we do now but I think this looks really
good it's definitely in children yeah
they're into it the the only kind of
navigational issue i had was really the
the home button i think that should just
be an UP button to take you back to that
home screen oh yeah and the other thing
was if you can go back to the home
screen for a second this home screen is
is gorgeous i love the custom typeface
and everything the one thing I would
consider doing is adding a little bit
more content in here so for example for
library you may want to have kind of the
the most recent or the the two most
recent color palettes that you've
created just so you can like jump back
into them very quickly without having to
go through the gallery and then the
library or incentives menu yes what one
thing we actually wanted to for the next
version we want to remove the main
screen and just move the user directly
to library in what do you think and
they'll have the because its is that the
first screen is month yeah you can
access everything from the action bar
with the camera and if you go drink it
to library you have access to all those
it's an interactive splash screen really
yeah i mean my suggestion would be like
as a first run splash screen i think
it's perfect it's something which comes
up and splays your brand in a way that's
really appealing and really shows people
that you care about design and given
that your target audience is designers I
think that's really important but I
think you're right i think the once
you've done that first pass on someone
so you can remove the library things
that's only going to be for the first
time and so right at the beginning you
choose between take a picture or choose
from the gallery to get that workflow
and then once you've done that once i
think you can skip that entirely and
then just launched the apps as you say
straight into straight into the library
juicer yeah i think it's a great work
for otherwise you know everything's good
here it's customized for us from
sandwich you've got i think that's a is
that a custom overflow menu is that a
pop-up menu rather than actual
so many we can yeah what I don't see the
oh you of course you don't say so what I
think it is correct yeah it's it's just
the the selector like the the red hue
that that happens when you press is just
a sustainable attribute of action I
think it actually does look at go the
1990s actually correct in it that's
great so you've got the overflow menu
you've got the action bar with actions
which is great in the icons the icons in
the action bar look a little dated you
may want to tweak them a little bit to
use our new iconography but okay cool
otherwise always nice i'm a big fan i
think this is something which around go
ahead and and suggest to the to the
editorial TW take a look at featuring
this was there any other specific
feedback that i have one thing back foot
for this for a tablet version of this
particular screen we have this outer
tablet just died i wasn't able to revive
it but imagine you what you're looking
at is a stretched screen for tablet
which overall looks very nice based on
our earlier comments but for this
particular screen I when I first looked
at it I pay so much attention to the
graphics here and then I missed the
bottom two buttons I had to you know go
back to the same screen a couple more
times to find it so maybe you can think
of ways or maybe on the tech bigger
screen make that two buttons on the
bottom or visible somehow make sense I'm
interested for the record of you I
choose the bottom to let you switch
between the image deuces the colors
associated with Uncle Fred and reminisce
they were preparing for today's from you
Romo gets all your strength from bananas
much like banana man for those of you
who are old enough to remember than
other men what look up around is it safe
for work is it not safe
say that's good boy who can sell one
yeah so awesome thank you thank you for
nominating your app it was so it was a
pleasurable okay great word um yeah
we'll send you some notes just to
summarize some of the suggestions that
we had afterwards but we'll don't really
be putting it forward and hopefully we
can see it featured somewhere in Google
Play great thanks thanks thanks for
joining us brilliant okay so that was
fun let's have a look what do we got up
next it's a notification agenda I think
is the the next app that we're going to
take a look at so I'm going to exit out
of here and find that up so this is a
notification agenda we've got on me on
the phone screen here as well at least
we will soon in the meantime um did you
guys have have any yeah yeah perfect yes
or are you gonna ask I was gonna ask
what you guys thought of it so maybe I
should give a bit of feedback first and
what the app is insurance all right so
what this is is basically a task list as
much as as far as i can tell but it's
sort of claim to fame its uniqueness
here is that every time you add a note
to your agenda you can make it become
persistent in your notification tray so
you just threw this one so you can see
here but test two has come up and if I
so you can see on the right hand side
we've got this little visibility icon
now one of my pieces of feedback here is
that this touch target is way too small
it impossible to press so I'm going to
try and use the very smallest part of my
pinky and you see it's now added that
note to my notification tray and then
you can toggle that and then we'll be at
it well that's a touch target that is a
touch tonight one thing I was impossible
to touch touch target but a touch target
nonetheless can make a note on that so I
actually had a Google+ post on the
exact problem a while ago maybe like
several months ago I remember this yeah
it was about touch delegates basically
the idea is that any time you have a
list item with inner targets like that
tiny little either you want to make sure
that your touch zones are simple and
like as big as possible so in this case
and I'm just a very summarize briefly
summarize what's the problem in this
case basically if you touch above or
below that that I you end up touching
the list item so you want to do is you
want to kind of simplify the zone so
that the left side of the list item is
basically the the list item itself and
the right side at least 48 dips and
width and the full height of that list
item is that secondary target I'm pretty
much a zero percent chance that
someone's going to try and hit the list
item just above go to the right hand
side of that uh-huh and in case you
can't make your view the full height of
the list item you can use something
called the touch delegate to basically
say you know when you touch the this
location on the parent view then
actually send that touch to the
secondary view so it's just a secondary
way of doing that yeah it's a really
good example of when this is the right
approach because this this looks good
here having the before I I don't think
you'd really want that to take up the
full listeners it would kind of be
cramped and I would hit the one below
and above it's having it inside i think
is the right approach but yeah you
definitely want to make sure that that's
touchable because otherwise you do what
I just did there we just click it then
it right now says unless if you click so
this is this is the no whew if so just
to finish off sort of the details
they've got a viewpager effect here so
that you can click across and choose
your icon and go back and edit the note
so that's that's all nice overall you I
look and feel is reasonable you've got
this sort of action bar like effect up
the topic no that's an actual action bar
but it looks like one it's not it's not
really an action bar
that's a crime side won nearly xanax
like one so to a certain degree that's
that's a reasonable approach but I think
room it's got some more detailed
comments yeah so yeah maybe you want to
you want to kick off that that's the
functionality right its notes him and
they persist in the notification train
so the I mean a lot of the comments that
I had were around the action bar so the
first the first issue is that you have
this up icon and the top left but it's
it's really it shows the home
iconography and the up iconography so
that's a little confusing so basically
you never want something that's both
home and up but it really should be
either home or up and generally should
prefer up since that's kind of the
formalized pattern and so for up you
basically just show your app icon and
it's a it's a way to introduce branding
into the app and kind of the little left
carrot the other issue is that on the
and the home screen yeah that top left
area is actually the overflow yeah let's
so let's go back to the to the phone
land and we can see this quite quite
clearly here so we've got this sort of
traditional action bar with the the
actions over here on the right with a
refreshin and create new and I just want
to point out that the create new icon
over here is actually looks a lot like
an edit icon now you may want to
consider replacing that with sort of the
thin plus symbol jepang is more than the
style and what Romans referring to over
here is is the app icon so I think to go
back to what you were saying before this
this is this should be consistent right
there should always be that icon and
they need it with the back up carrot or
not I mean it doesn't necessarily have
to be that icon it should be some sort
of iconography or a logo or nothing at
all but definitely the the home icon
like having the the home button that's
that's kind of deprecated you should no
longer use done okay so um but so here's
the really interesting thing is that so
as an Android user I think what we all
expect is that if you hit something with
a drop down on this side is going to be
navigation
in gmail when you choose between your
inboxes or labels and here it's actually
the overflow menu which is a little
quite edible it reminds me of Mac OS X
right you touch me the Apple and gives
you the system preferences that's very
strange on Android I've seen people
duplicating iphone OS paradigms on
Android never before mac OS i think is
new so this is just confusing bottom
line it's you're not expecting an
overflow menu here it means that it
either completely undiscoverable or
completely unintuitive so it's fine to
have these things but they should
totally be on the Nova flow menus over
here on the far right hand so having the
consistency would be pretty important
yeah users so for these sorts of things
is like this is no user is ever going to
expect this and where they when they are
looking for settings are going to be
expecting them over on this side so
that's it's kind of a must fix straight
away get on it I so two more slow
actually one more general thing is when
you get into the the edit or the detail
of you um there are one two three four
different ways in which you can accept
or cancel basically if you if you press
back it cancels if you press up it also
cancels if you press the X it also
cancels the only way to actually save is
to press the check box interest so what
you should do is you should simplify
this so in general you don't want users
to lose progress right so if i just
typed out and i know this is for a
notification so it's probably a very
short note but if i just typed out
something fairly important like a phone
number or an ID or something that i have
to remember pressing back should not
just cancel it it should probably save
it and just automatically assume that
the user meant press ok or you know if
you absolutely have to then show the
dialog saying actually do you want to
save or not but what it does now is is
dan correct behavior i think is that you
know it actually just discards right
well i think the first option you
mentioned is the preferred way in an
opinion ya like like a gmail behavior
right when you're composing a net and
email when you press back it
automatically saves your
email message in progress into draft
Pacific's I think it kind of implies I
don't know how it works behind the
scenes but it implies that if you know
if I'm typing away something detailed
here and then I get an incoming phone
call and then that comes I'd rather do
something else and the app gets killed
sometime in the background you know I'm
not convinced here that when i started
up it's going to be saved that's right
and I think you know you make a good
point as three ways to not save your
information and only one way to save it
kind of implies that not saving your
information is is more important than
saving it now can't think of any
situations with that slightly case now
so you want to switch that priority
around an ad I'm having a vision of the
ends from the UI team telling me
something along the lines not even need
to have an X button it's but yeah just a
tick and you press that in it and it
goes back and there's a way to do that
with the action bar exam so we invite
too there's like a like an except
there's a way to sell it yeah I'm happy
with this edit yeah so so the top left
and in some of our apps we actually have
the top left as a checkbox and done and
you can you can't do that using like by
just simply saying I'll do that you have
to provide I think a custom view and but
it's easier to probably grab it from the
open source project in and do it but
basically the top left you don't even
need the icon at or an UP button it
could just be done checkbox done yes and
in the top right having something like
this card with your text I scarred yeah
and then that's a nice effect because I
need to be basically saying like this is
just a temporary modal scenario where
you want to do something and then just
hit and go back to where you're from is
minimizing the number of different ways
to interact with that particular screen
right yeah basically if I've gone to the
screen I've already made the conscious
decision to save something so that
should be the default kind of the
default expectations that the user
actually wants to save with their
writing right so you have to make the
assumption that the user would have to
consciously cancel it yet and you cancel
yeah like oh I've made this Western
applause they can go away
okay nice now I know there was a couple
of interesting things to I think with
the action bar that I think you guys
noticed before we were taking a look at
the app am I remembering correctly
beside sizing I think I mentioned all
the things that I I noticed um I thought
there was a way that you could honor has
a different that's different uh nope
that yes it also has a green action
button yes that's about using two notes
out this is seen action work of it
excellent excellent okay so sad one more
suggestion is that you know when you're
in edit mode it's just a text screen
where you can input some information and
swipe right and you pick an icon when
you go back ideally I'd like to see the
selected icon to display somewhere here
to give me an indication that okay this
is the guy icon that's going to be
displayed next to the notification
something scope it easier right all
mostly I'm preview below it show yeah
because identification takes a known
amount of space which isn't right that
significance yeah that there would be a
great suggestion especially you know on
the tablet which used to be running high
when i first tested it on a tablet you
know imagine again what you're looking
at here is an expanded screen you have a
lot of white space and this developer
you produce should look into increasing
the side margins a little bit to make it
look visually nice and I'm sure Roman
has more for sure yeah i mean the
padding for sure can of worms the
padding for sure something you could do
with the the titles as I think we
mention this in the Hangout office hours
but a neat thing to do is just I use the
list separator text view style as the
heading and then completely remove
completely remove the background on the
text fields themselves so the text field
effectively becomes just an open area
like inviting you to type content and
then you apply the kind of the border to
indicate the different regions on the
headers not on the text field nice so
yeah so overall I think it's definitely
not good potential it is kind of a very
simple idea but if it's kind of a good
way of being able to put things in
which is visible what 11 little bit of
feedback but I did have in terms of
functionality is that I thought it would
be nice once you've got these
notifications here to be able to dismiss
these so these aren't dismissible as you
can see by the fact that they're
bouncing back but if I could dismiss
this and then it would just toggle that
visibility flow mini and I think that
would be kind of a neat thing because I
could see this would be a much more
convenient shopping list app for me and
always gotta milk the goat cheese
exactly gangs swipe and I'd love to
navigate through an app or any of that
time consuming to keep the little box
it's just bang bang bang bang bang so
that to me would actually make this
really I think you can specify in the
notifications framework a dismiss intent
so that when it gets dismissed you can
actually go ahead and disable its ear
until I kind of have a sink or anything
you just get a notification for an event
rather when when it gets this mess yeah
exactly so that would be my big tip so I
would say you know think think about
that the main thing I think here is
around some of the UI elements i think
tidy down up and you're going to have
something which is a lot more intuitive
for people to use absolutely cool any
other comments to move on let's move on
all right brilliant so this is the other
app that i was thinking of g notes junos
but so let's take a study notes we're
coming on a theme green thing yes
exactly so all right you know this i can
see why i was confused this is a similar
similar sort of thing going on dear
somali the pseudo action bar sort of
scenario yeah why don't you guys come
tulsa a little bit about this app idea
what do you think what we thought so
again it's just it's notes right
different different way of collecting
nuts it's notes I think that I mean for
me I'm a UI guy sometimes just get
blinded by the bed mixels and I don't
actually see what the app does but the
one thing I really noticed that i
did--like in this Notes app is that
there are a lot of ways to take notes
right you can you can capture audio you
can
take a photo with your camera in
whatever and everybody has a different
way of taking notes right so I
personally just do text some people do
voice notes and things like that so what
this app does really well is it actually
lets you customize the the action bar if
you touch the top right you see kind of
all the different ways of taking a note
you can actually drag one of those items
into the action bar that's a pretty cool
feature yeah to make it a conscious like
kind of you're telling the app this is
how I like to take notes right so that
the ability to personalize and customize
is really cool what happens if your
track tried drank more icons it doesn't
accept it oh yeah it doesn't hear item
JJ replaces the logo but I'm telephone
did you get after three at a time it's
pretty innovative stuff yeah yeah well
like that yeah and it's probably almost
certainly using a custom action bar
which in this case i mean what i would
do is borrowed in this i would use the
standard action bar but i would have a
custom action view that was kind of wide
enough to take two or three icons that
would act as the drop target and not
kind of rewrite the entire action bar
just to do that it's a good point
because you can you can have that custom
custom action p which has holds the
functionality included transparent
background so that it just stands on top
that would be nice but yeah it's
definitely definitely useful
functionality so again you can take your
photo picture notes
good that's beautiful ring all right
that's what Raymond looks like without
the fancy purchasing we doing let's go
back into ultra mode so it's nice to see
that this and memos the apps we've
looked at today or all work really well
in landscape and portrait mode which is
which is awesome so that's that's a note
of Roman in his beautiful glory um and
we can add additional context yeah Roman
so this app is a good example which
takes exactly the opposite approach to
the one we were looking up beforehand
where I don't think that there is a way
to cancel what you're doing you
basically just go back now now I have to
say that because it's not always clear
like some apps don't save everything I'm
kind of looking on the screen here for a
wait to confirm that I want to save this
note I don't want to lose it and all I
get is two back buttons so that kind of
breaks another rule of having on screen
back button yes you don't need to all
right what I would suggest here is
actually really simple as just turn that
into it into a tick into an exception
and then you kind of got exactly the
same functionality as you're doing now
but it's a little more obvious to me
yeah but this has been you know the
difference between and we when we first
introduced up people were like that's
back right and it is very it's different
it's for sure different we have been a
documentation in the navigation section
of Android design on this but sometimes
to a user the difference can actually be
an iconography right that icon looks
like back the the up icon it's a left
carrot but where users are trained over
the course of using their device they're
trained to understand that that left
carrot and that those exact angles and
that exact with that actually represents
something else besides back and it's
almost subtle it's not you know if you
ask a user what does that they'll say
bag do they know that it behaves diff
and so when you when you start
introducing iconography the counter that
their expectations change right yeah
that's a minute something which we get
asked about a lot like you know should
shoot every app look exactly the same as
specified in the guidelines is there
room for divergence there and there
absolutely is the key is really just to
make sure that user expectations are met
so that when you're pressing something
you have a really high degree of
confidence that it's going to do what
you want to do so i think that's that's
kind of the key and the other thing i
would like to point out is that not only
does this does this app have a soft back
button on the screen that we just saw
and i believe if you hook into the
settings no setup setup actually suit no
menu settings go back go back this and
basically there's another style of that
button oh it's a different stuff but i
can't for some reason case the
collapseexpand but yeah this guy at this
back button oh god oh yeah what's out of
two strikes and then that'll be the f
softback final is going with that there
yeah you know what you don't have actual
back button that's not pretty you also
have an actual back button that's next
to the hard back buttons yes all right
away that's unfortunate um let's see the
other the other interesting come into it
so this goes along the same life line
too confusing iconography so up here
we've got what looks it's pretty small
on-screen here so even at seven twenty I
don't know that you guys are going to
see what that is but it's instead of the
app icon and it's got a tiny little left
triangle next to it and so that looks
like it should be up right yeah but it
isn't it's it's collapse which actually
makes more sense in this context as to
what it is but that was totally fake to
me I had no idea what that was going to
do jet suggestions is to a better way to
sort of display that kind of an arm so
the the closest pattern to this I'd say
is is something that we see more on
tablets and portrait this is the second
if you could
Android design again and you go to
multi-pane layouts there's a section
that talks about orientation change so
how to deal with fragments specifically
on portrait and landscape but you know
making sure that you have the same
functionality across both and in this
case you don't have two fragments you
really just have a kind of alternative
navigation along the left side and so I
don't think that you know it makes too
much sense to have this you may be able
to do the same exact thing by offering
kind of left and right swipe or or even
a drop down in the action bar but if you
absolutely positively have to stick with
something like this what I would make
sure to do is follow the kind of that
pattern on tablet basically the idea is
that that up button is always up if you
press it if you press it and that left
pane is not visible then it shows the
left pane it should probably slide in to
indicate kind of best yeah but then when
if you press it again it shouldn't
collapse it you should basically just be
going up the hierarchy not kind of
toggle expired between yeah so that's
one thing I recommend but again I think
the basic recommendation here is I think
not to use this kind of side pane first
of all on a phone and portrait it limits
your horizontal space which is general
not a good thing to do I think they're
just other ways to do this that you the
same result how does it look in that
scheme quickly I was going to say as
well along the same lines that up you
know an alternative to that is to
basically have thee that's it makes a
little bit more sense in in landscape
having that calm down yeah because you
got the extra horizon-- win but one
thing which you might want to consider
as an alternative is to use sort of the
more standard action bar navigation very
similar to what gmail does we have a
drop down here which lets you select a
witch of the books that you want to have
so gmail does this really well with
labels and with accounts so that's
probably the approach that I think
another comment here just generally the
the COG here implies settings what it
kind of really is is the ability to
either add a new book or modify the
existing ones that's not entirely in yo
to me the way that works and I'd
consider sort of simplifying this so the
COG becomes a plus
and all you do there is create a new
book and that should probably be an
action or something along those lines
and then edit could have to be a
settings menu thing so I already wrote
to too much detail that but just
generally speaking I think it's a little
bit more confusing the last bit is that
there's a legacy menu button there there
is sustained by dry ice cream truck
gambia so actually yeah it does stuff
which means it's not technically a
bottom of shame Rohach is good but yeah
you want to you can really easily change
this into an overflow menu again the
same functionality so I wouldn't do that
I didn't like that got some nice
drag-and-drop action here so yeah there
they've actually got a thumbnail here
and you can drag it onto the tube into
the latest cool interestingly the other
bin graphics look a little grainy like
it's too it's too small it's just being
pulled up yeah i'm guessing it's been
borrowed from somewhere in the the
framework and there's just no hdpi or
xhdpi assets for it so again I think
about maybe in fact it's just a rounded
rectangle with an icon in it so you may
be able to do something using a durable
i shaped horrible to cheaper in a
scalable way okay any other comments on
that one that covers it i think that the
one really cool thing is i mean the
dragging in here is well done i think
there are some some like flickering
issues or whatever but the dragon
overall it's a cool concept absolutely
absolutely all right so i think that
takes us to just about 45 path so i
think rather than look at the next two
apps will call them off scenario next
time so yeah so that should pretty much
wrap us up do stay tuned we've got Ian
Lewis and Dan Galpin ian is currently
acting as our producer behind scenes he
will be coming to front of camera where
he belongs to host the operator review
games edition so we up in just 15
minutes like we mentioned earlier all of
the apps which we look at here our self
nominated by their creators for us to
take a look at will be sending them some
additional feedback
finished here you would like to have
your app review by us there is a
moderator page which you can get at the
Android developers Google+ page at
developer.android.com / + will be sure
to post that there along with the video
from this session so we can check out
your apps thank you very much for
everyone who did nominate this week a
particular particularly development of
real colors pro both for creating an
awesome app and for joining us on the
show tells ya good enough good stuff
cool alright so thank you guys for
joining me i hope that i'll see you next
week and yes along the way it's a longer
now come on ok now you gotta fall and
how are you man i don't know how you do
it thank you again oh so in the meantime
till we see you all next week I just
need a piece out your eyes
you